hi I'm Erik Bosse and Pokemon detective
Pikachu has arrived with a trailer for
this live-action Pokemon adventure
mystery if you're like me this may have
brought up some questions where did this
movie come from why is Pikachu talking
with Ryan Reynolds voice and most
importantly Britta my bomb hide my old
gameboy because I'm feeling a sudden
urge to catch things I'm gonna break
down this trailer shot-by-shot
for all the fun little details that you
might have missed and explain what
exactly this movie is and why it could
turn out to be a super charming hit that
would justify being a grown man and
spending money on plush dolls spoiler
warning in case any of these predictions
end up revealing too much and let's get
started
welcome to rhyme city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
okay this opening clip introduces our
hero Tim Goodman played by Justice Smith
he may have seen in Jurassic world
fallen Kingdom he's arriving at rhyme
City this movie's adapted from the
Pokemon spin-off game detective Pikachu
which came out earlier this year
actually in 2016 in Japan this game is a
bit different it has a talking Pikachu
who helps Tim Goodman investigate a
mystery behind an are drug that's
released Kazi and Pokemon two rampage
and the setting of the game is this
place rhyme city it's somewhere in the
Olalla region the seventh main region
established in the Pokemon universe and
looking closely at this opening crowd
shot it is filled with various
live-action come on there are actually
two dodrio x' he also passes a
Charmander up in the air you can see a
comfy floating among some flabébé
there's also some bird type Pokemon
looks kind of like a pidgeotto maybe a
Fiero and a huge breviary perched on the
ground and looking deep in the
background the crowd there's a buffalo
and a venusaur lumbering around way back
there really this is a fully integrated
Pokemon world on the buildings on the
right there's a sign for berries those
were introduced to the games and the
gold and silver generation and in the
next shot we meet Lucy Stevens a
reporter who teams up with Tim and
detective Pikachu she is a psychic like
misty but Psyduck was pretty unwieldy
that was more of a who had who situation
and behind them you can see inflatable
parade balloons for Gengar and
Jigglypuff and one last detail before I
move on I like how they featured this
music
Timm which you might recognize is the
opening music from the Pokemon games
[Music]
cool let's move on your card was a
legend in this precinct if you are
anything like your talent
and this clip tim learns about his
decorated police father Harry Goldman
from Harry's friend detective Yashida
played by Ken Watanabe now whatever
happened to his father it's clear Tim
starts the movie feeling a bit
disconnected from his old man but I'm
guessing through his relationship with
detective Pikachu Tim will hopefully fix
these daddy issues and we could see Tim
with some probably a mundane desk job
with the mystery of his father leading
him into the world of animal catching
and cage fighting like I'm not judging
I'm just saying this world we've spent
her childhood success in over has some
weird ethics on to the next clip I
remember you wanted to be a pokemon
trainer anyway yeah yeah they didn't
really work out
okay here we see Tim going through the
bedroom covered in all these posters of
major Pokemon battles as if their boxing
matches there's some interesting
matchups here Dragonite in hypno mm-hmm
my money's probably on Dragonite there I
like that they include the Pokemon
dollar currency symbol with the P at the
double strikethrough there's also a
poster for a fight at the johto sport
club doto is the name of the second
major region in pokemon world and there
it's artic universe steelix
yeah okay metal types are pretty strong
against ice is it have to be one tough
artic univer that they even be close to
fair it's also a championship poster for
the cerulean arena presumably that's in
cerulean city in Kanto that's where
Misty's gym is located and over the desk
you can see a poster showing a Loudred
that's the super loud pokemon introduced
in generation 3 and above the Pikachu
ear headboard other poster shows the
cinah championship 24 shinobi in the 4th
region and one more poster behind Tim
appears to show Zekrom and Reshiram
those are two of the three members of
the tau trio legendary Pokemon the
Innova region introduced in generation 5
in this 21st birthday card for Tim it
looks like he had been invited to come
stay in rhyme City with someone having
bypass train ticket forum if you look
closely you can see that the departure
City is leave in town or 11 town now
most of the cities in Pokemon features
some kind of wordplay so I suppose this
house whole reason for existing is to be
a place that you leave and let us move
on know how to use this
uh geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you okay in this
section we meet this movies Pikachu a
detective voiced by Brian Reynolds now I
will say it it's a little weird for
Deadpool to be the voice of B kachou at
first I was like are they just trying to
do what Marvel did with Bradley Cooper
and Rocket Raccoon really Reynolds
brings kind of gruff rough around the
edges hard-ass that best matches the
voice from the detective Pikachu game
which is one detail players of the game
really enjoyed don't tell me you confuse
this guy for me I also just really like
the animation detail to get Pikachu a
furry texture it just makes the
character seems so much more tactile and
weighty in huggable compared to these
smooth designs that we've seen another
animated versions where he looks kind of
like a yellow water balloon next clip
did you just talk whoa did you just
understand me oh my god you can
understand me I've been so long okay
here they realize that Tim can
understand Pikachu's words as English as
opposed to the pika pika sounds that
everyone else hears now I don't want to
think too hard about this but this does
bring up questions ID Pokemon our
animals they're monsters the sounds they
make is some version of their names or
sometimes just roaring or growling are
like the general sounds that any other
animal would make not a sophisticated
language with specific words that
translate from it like when a dog barks
at you it's not a dog language that
could be translated to English sorry
Doug from up the brain does not work
like that you're a dog there is a world
of difference or made German Shepherd
barking at us and a German Shepherd
speaking German to us now we can assume
detective Pikachu is just a way smaller
Pokemon from all the others the way
detective Cumberbatch is smarter than
all other humans but that doesn't
explain why only Tim can hear him like
either Tim would have to have some kind
of unique auditory nerve or more likely
Tim and detective Pikachu just share a
magical connection but would this mean
that each and every Pokemon has a human
soul mate somewhere out there who can
understand them and they're just yelling
words that is constantly hoping that
we're the ones for them and somehow only
one pair has found each other that's
tragic
no no just makes the think twice about
locking them up in tiny balls and making
them fight each other movie not the try
to talk to me all the time all they hear
is pika pika
you can hear him
if you could beat guys adorable you're
adorable they can't understand me
kitchen no one else okay in this section
there are a ton of Pokemon sightings if
you look closely there's another dodrio
in the middle of this Lane as well as an
odd Dino and on top of one of the booths
you can see a group of Emolga and it
looks like you can see another flabebe
near them on the bar top of one of the
booths on the right are a few Joel tick
and a Charmander uses its tail to heat
the stove and another booth that Pikachu
passes and later shot of the street you
can see another venusaur beside Tim and
what kind of looks like a go work way in
the background now when this couple
interacts with Pikachu the voice reverts
back to a familiar one movie you got the
original Pikachu voice actor at KU a
itani to do it and maybe I'm just seeing
things but don't those stalks behind
Pikachu look like the leaks that
Farfetch'd carries around let's move on
I don't need a Pokemon period and what
about a world-class detective because if
you want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me okay this section hint said
the movies whole conspiracy mystery plot
suggesting that Tim's father is still
alive but that may be a hit was put on
him when he was investigating some
missing Pokemon you can see the Flyers
on his wall showing a missing squirtle
and a missing Pancham which I gotta say
is pretty inconvenient because it's kind
of hard to distinguish between one
squirtle and another oh come on don't
get triggered you know the sunglasses
was the only way you could tell them
apart next
[Music]
it brought us together and that magic
key is called hope
[Music]
that's cool-looking Bulbasaur heard
along with some floating morale oh I
love the bioluminescent effect they gave
the spores behind them you can see Tim
holding Pikachu appears to be injured
maybe they're all leading them to a
place to restore Pikachu's health and
next we see Jigglypuff singing at the
cafe putting the kind of sleep I love
the joke of this being an espresso bar
like the caffeine wasn't enough to
resist it gets a song Jigglypuff
definitely looks pissed as usual I'm
starting to tell if it's holding a
marker they're just a real microphone
probably a marker and the wall behind
them there's another matchup poster
between Machamp and primate she's like a
pretty good fight considering they're
both fighting types that they're most
evolved pieces and then there's this
fierce look in Charizard and a cage
fighting arena followed by these three
green ninjas and then Tim and Pikachu
peering into that fighting arena with
squirtle and Pancham visible now I want
to say these are the missing ones though
I don't want to assume maybe the reason
these Pokemon are missing is that
they're running away to fight in these
underground fighting bits also beside
Tim and Pikachu isn't rough 'let and in
the next shot when Tim and Pikachu are
escaping explosions a tunnel chasing
them are a couple of atheon and maybe
it's a light but doesn't it kind of look
like their eyes are glowing maybe
they're just pissed or maybe they're
high on that are drugged if the movie
follows the plot of the game and before
I move on there are some shots of Tim
and Lucy with pikachu and psyduck
watching as the terrain bends up over
them like it's inception or dr. strange
or something now this could be caused by
another legendary Pokemon maybe
something like Torterra but I don't
think two were tears that big maybe this
is like a herd of Onix is pushing it the
land like this moving on we got ways to
make you talk or Mon tell us what we
want to know pushing my problem is that
I push people away and then hate them
for leaving he's saying you can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop you're good cop
in my head I saw that differently okay I
gotta say mr. mime is always creeping
the hell out like how is this an animal
is it wearing clothes or is that it's
naked skin are the shoes part of its
body or does it put them on is there a
mrs. mine probably not since mr. mime
can be female sometimes haha hey in case
you're confused what Pikachu slammed
into there mr. mime is probably using
its move barrier it's very effective and
on to the last clip
[Music]
okay in this last clip Pikachu can be
seen running from the greninja
suggesting that these things are
henchmen of whomever the villain is we
also see Psyduck using some shock wave
attack which could be size shock or
psybeam psychic maybe just a real badass
version of screech and it ends with
Pikachu falling into the open jaws of
Charizard I'm thinking that maybe in
order to save these missing Pokemon who
ended up in the fighting pit Pikachu
might volunteer as tribute to try to
topple the ranking champ and spare them
its wrath Charizard is part flying-type
like Electric Pikachu would have an
advantage there I mean if this was just
every episode of the animated series it
would just end with Pikachu use
Thunderbolt ooh blowing everything up
Charizard is messed up again speaking of
which here's what I want to know what do
you think is a villain of this movie
Team Rocket
Mewtwo who is a Pokemon that detective
Pikachu is a history within the game or
someone else comment down below with
your thoughts thanks to our sponsors
Skillshare for helping us make this
video skill share is an online learning
community with thousands of classes and
design business technology and more it's
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to high-quality classes on
must-know topics so you can improve your
skills unlock new opportunities and do
the work you love while watching this
trailer for Pokemon detective Pikachu
I'm amazed to see the detail in the
animation and how the designers really
nailed that idea of some Pokemon looking
cute and huggable
now there's be terrifying this don't got
me really interested in the animation
and film editing a subject I know very
little about so to get started I use
skill sure to take rich armstrong's
class synthetic stop-motion and After
Effects quick and easy techniques for
handmade animations and as someone with
only the most rudimentary understanding
in post-production it was a great
introduction and how to use Adobe After
Effects to create some cool animated
visuals for videos Skillshare is also
more affordable than most learning
platforms out there an annual
subscription is less than $10 a month
but we're gonna do a special offer just
for you guys the first 500 people to
sign up with the link in the description
below will get their first two months
for free just go to sk l dot sh / new
rockstars 8 or click on the link in the
description and following new rock stars
on twitter & instagram at new rock stars
and prom eyes sometimes unsettling hot
takes follow me on twitter and instagram
binet e fan I'm just warning you this
as a high body count and I can't promise
Pikachu makes it out okay but I will do
everything in my powers who save him
this Friday November 16th 8 p.m. acne
theater North Hollywood ticket info in
the description below and subscribe to
new rock stars for more breakdowns of
everything you love now I'm gonna get
out of here because I feel like mr. mime
is around here somewhere